i undervalued communication and i
undervalued
me liking the guy it was always like am
i good enough am i hot enough
am i competing amongst these other women
instead of
flipping it to like is this guy good
enough does he even have a job
you know he was late
chrissy may welcome to the show thanks
for having me have you managed to get
dog poo off your shoe
yeah you know it's starting to be
springtime here in new york and part of
that
means going around the yard and picking
up poops
and throwing them over the fence
why is that only a springtime thing what
happens in winter
well what happens in winter is they get
covered in the snow and then
when the snow melts like all the poops
appear like ah
that's kind of what's been happening
here in new york
you're like damn somebody had a busy
winter and then you like say it to the
dog and you're like
yeah i was walking i went on a little
walk earlier on
this is like a weird thing that people
who love dogs but don't have a dog do
so whenever someone that's coming
towards me on the street is walking a
dog on a leash
i won't make eye contact at all with the
other person
because this is my 15 seconds of dog
attention for like potentially for the
day you know if i have a bad walk and i
don't pick up many dogs
so i just but i wonder what they must
think of me
because i'm just this psychopath walking
past staring at their dog like longingly
staring at their dog because i love dogs
because they're awesome
and um yeah yeah i just wonder
i wonder if it weighs people out
uh it actually makes me feel really good
to hear that you do exactly what i do i
could not care
less about the owner like exactly like i
i hoard as much dog time as possible
like
i almost think like you know like when i
was in new york city more like there'd
be dog walkers and then you'd be like
jackpot you know i like to cross the
street just to meet a dog
and then like i'm like what would be
like the next level thing that like the
dog just couldn't
i think if you just laid down that would
be the thing the dog like could not
avoid at that point it's like the dog is
gonna jump on you
so the humans like the humans just there
to facilitate you looking at a dog
basically
yeah and and when i walk actually it's
like my
my boyfriend's mom's dog but i feel like
we're like close like i was there the
day she came home
so i feel like i don't know we're like
we're close buds
if when people just go up to muffin i
don't take it as a personal offense i'm
just like no she's
super effing cute like of course muffin
muffins she likes to come in
during my uh podcast recordings and then
she'll like she'll sort of like put her
paws up on me and like look but then
sometimes
while doing that she'll kick out my
internet cord fantastic
which uh is less cute when you have like
a really
high profile guest i'm like oh [ __ ] and
then you got to plug it back in
can i curse i've been cursing curse away
curse away i want to talk
about all of the common mistakes that
women make when they're growing up
and how to deal with them do you think
you are you qualified for this
i'm very qualified i have made almost
all of the mistakes
so yeah i think i think i'm
definitely qualified to talk about
mistakes in my
uh 20 something odd years of life no no
it's like you don't really know
until you become 37. now i can
confidently
confidently look back and be like oh
yeah like if i had a younger
like sister or niece or something like
just a girl in her like late teens early
20s i'd be like sit down
all right take out a notebook
all right so where do you want to start
what's what's first
oh there's so much and uh and that's the
thing is to start with it's
maybe it's part of the i don't know if
it's like this in the uk but it's
definitely part of american culture to
like
fully blame women or fully blame men it
seems like the easy cop-out thing
that you see folks doing is like like
women love to say oh
all men are stupid or just totally group
overly grouping
people like overly grouping the sexes
like oh
men are dumb all men do this and then
it's easy for guys who aren't having
luck to be like
women are crazy there's you know there's
no chance
you know it's too much it's too
difficult and that's
that's what it is is like you have to
keep going out there despite getting
hurt it's like
yeah that's that's also life you know i
think it's
just in the last couple decades we've
like glamorized
as a culture like like
the lack of hard work and i think that
kind of bleeds over to relationships our
jobs our goals like how we live our
lives it's like
i think we need to just make in general
hard work
like cool again and i've had like
versions of this conversation with so
many people but when it comes to
relationships i yeah i can only observe
like what i've seen
like what messages i've absorbed as a
woman
and usually like a lot of young women
will go for their sources of
advice or information like magazines or
like for me i know like magazines were
big growing up or like
like now it's kind of all of this is
mixed online so it's like our magazines
our news our apps is all kind of in this
online world
and that's where we go for advice
because like we don't talk to our
parents our parents aren't cool
maybe we don't have older siblings like
or maybe our parents aren't like my
parents weren't in a healthy
relationship they stayed together but
they didn't like they weren't
like from what i could observe they
didn't like each other they weren't kind
to each other
and on one side it was great because i
developed my sense of humor from their
kind of like sarcastic
constant back look constantly roasting
and
undercutting each other and so that was
good for like developing my sense of
humor but
for developing my sense of like what
should i look for in a partner it was
[ __ ]
and uh you know a lot of times like like
as women yeah we'll seek out like
magazines or advice from now it's like
apps and
all these articles and um
that is so not the place to go because
there's so much bad advice in these like
consumerist
spaces and i think so much of that is
online and it just seems so easy
to go for everything online because
that's like our our whole world is just
in our pocket and we're looking we're
checking it
50 times a day and that was like a big
thing i learned from you
actually chris the last time we did a
show together i've started charging my
phone outside the room
i'm like good night phone and then i go
into my room and i shut the door and i
kind of feel like free i'm like
free at last doesn't know that i'm in
here yeah they can't get me while the
phone's outside
that's such an interesting point about
girls and role models because we hear a
lot about
guys don't have the role models that
they need at the moment the jordan
peterson movement
was this kind of um father to a million
men
so to speak we don't actually hear that
about girls but you're saying that
young girls are also a little bit or can
be a bit directionless without role
models too
it's so it's just in our nature to be
and i don't want to speak for all women
but like i think a lot of women have
this people-pleasing
gene i think it's what makes us good
friends good mothers good listeners
good nurturers it's like your strengths
and your weaknesses are always kind of
together right and we could go off on
like what they are for men too but
there's something kind of uniquely
female about people pleasing
and like we're perceptive we can figure
out what people
want and give it to them without even
having them
to act like without their asking and i
think women all like well
and i can definitely speak for myself
like i would expect that in my
relationships and that's
that's what's coming up for me a lot in
my current relationship because we've
been together
six years and i still struggle with this
like well i can read
his mind i think like why can't he read
mine or like
when and that covers everything from
like what i
want to eat to sexually you know what i
mean and i go well i figured your [ __ ]
out like
you know not to get too graphic but
i'm pretty good you know
yeah it's so that's i i think that
you're right the agreeableness
that girls have is so pervasive
like it's crazy when i think to
some the levels of disagreeableness that
my most disagreeable girl
friends are like in fact i would put it
out there that michaela peterson is the
most disagreeable girl that i've ever
met in my life
and i yeah she was on my podcast too and
i i was
i was amazed i was like of course you're
jordan peterson's daughter like look at
you like
you're just like you're such a bad [ __ ]
and you're like just don't apologize
i don't know why i guess because my mom
was very much i think it's helpful to
look at your mom
because you're you're gonna absorb i
think more from your mother
than you do from your father it's
interesting like if i had a
really great father that was like
talking to me all the time and giving a
[ __ ] about my feelings
i think that would have uh manifested in
the way of like maybe i would have had a
better picker
for in terms of guys and i think that's
how that [ __ ] with me but
my mom is my example like i was
you're almost like it's a default like
it's your template for your behaviors
i think and i never saw my mom like
really stand up for herself like my my
dad didn't like beat my mom
but like he definitely was like not
super nice to her and the way he would
talk to her
and um just made her feel bad a lot from
what i could pick up on
and like they always fought about money
and
my dad would say stuff to my thanks to
my mom like oh
like the kids are messy it's all your
fault because you didn't teach them to
do
chores like he was so and he these are
boomers right and so
you gotta if i'm gonna throw them a bone
like
they're kind of imprinted with this
thinking of like oh like my dad very
much thought he could he handled the
outside work and outside the house was
for men
and inside work the kids happened to be
inside the house well so
that's a mom's responsibility but it's
interesting because now that my mom's
passed away and we just have dad it's
almost
and i like now it's like i don't i can
easily go a month without talking to him
and now he'll i'll kind of talk to and
i'm good like
i figured out my business i like through
a combination of like
therapy and having the right people
around me challenging me i've kind of
filled in my own
gaps and i'm good but when i talk on the
phone to my dad he'll say things like
you know just like call me if you ever
need advice or you ever
and it's like i feel like he's kind of
pawing at something and it's and it's
not to be cruel it's like yeah i'm good
dad you know what i mean like it's
almost like he's going for something
that he hasn't
built you know what i mean like well the
other thing as well is
there's this weird point that everybody
gets to both guys and girls
where your parents stop being the
teachers and start being the students
there isn't a single person listening
that hasn't had to teach their mum and
dad how to
unlock the ipad or to use internet
banking or to order something from
amazon or do or whatever
like yeah everybody's had to do that and
there's some point where the wisdom
direction gets reversed and you're now
teaching your parents and this is
probably being exacerbated because our
parents generation and our generation
are
so different all of the rules that they
used to play the game by now they no
longer work
it's not about a job for life it's not
about
hard work and seniority will get you
through the end it's about
like understanding networking and
communication skills online and stuff
like that these are skills that have
only come about
since we've been here how could they
have ever learned them and then
yeah it is when the power dynamic
switches
and um there is a little bit of guilt i
can kind of get what you mean there that
you almost feel like
not patronizing but like a sense of
obligation to still
let the parent feel the respect
like you don't want them to now feel
like the child you're like look i still
need to
like you say throw them a bone so to
speak um yeah it's odd it's so weird
when that happens i don't know when it
happens i think it's about sort of early
20s 25 maybe
it is odd and there's such a difference
between like of course i'll show
i'll show my parents or somebody older
or like my boyfriend's parents like a
tech thing and and sometimes there are
boomers or like slightly younger boomers
who are better at it they take it upon
themselves to learn these new skills and
it's like i don't mind showing
someone the same like technical thing
over and over again but like
i think my unique thing with my dad is
like you didn't put time in
into developing a relationship with me
like throughout my whole life
because that was always mom's job like
you know always when you call
call mom or mom calls you like my mom
would be like oh how's this thing how's
that thing even if she didn't like
understand or know about like the
intricacies of like my goals or comedy
or whatever she would ask about them
and then it would just be like pass the
phone to dad dad would kind of check in
but really like mom was like holding it
down a lot of moms are like this moms
are like the glue
and dad is just like okay how's your car
all right
bye you know but now that the glue is
gone
uh it's a little sad because my dad is
just like oh if you ever need anything
it's like no i
i don't because i've learned to go my
whole life without
needing you for emotional support or
and then i would kind of pride myself on
growing to not need his financial
support but that's
could be a whole other podcast but the
point is it's interesting because
what i was imprinted with from my dad
was a little bit like
i did kind of grow up to be a little bit
afraid of men because he
he would spank you know like and that's
what a lot of baby boomers would do it's
like you get in trouble and i would just
for some reason test him all the time
and then i got to college and i became
like a dumb woke liberal and i would
irritate him even more
you know like fighting with him about
the homeless you know like [ __ ] that
didn't really matter to my life
i just had to fight with him on
everything and i just i would piss him
off
constantly um but but he was just
he would lose his temper and then
sometimes he would like spank and so
like that imprinted me
the rest of my life being kind of afraid
of men and i'm definitely afraid to
challenge men
and and if there was a time even if a
guy i was dating or a male boss would
like
even raise their voice or even start to
feel like
they weren't pleased with me it would
trigger that
whatever in me that like not this
feeling like oh you're about to get hit
but like it's it's just like
you learn this when you go to therapy
like what your sort of what your inner
child
or what your child self develops like
out of survival
and how it affects you as you grow up so
that was that's
been my challenge as an adult like okay
even if even if you disagree
with a male authority figure or your
boyfriend like
that doesn't mean like shrink shrivel
pull back
be easy be a people be okay with
whatever
be like whatever you want or oh it's not
worth it or like
it's not worth the fight it's not worth
the conflict
it's not worth the argument and uh
pulling away from like having a
different opinion does not equal
this is an argument this is a conflict
this is something to
shy away from because if you do that
enough uh you
lose yourself in a relationship the it's
like you're
if and when this um comes to a boyfriend
you're actually like
robbing that guy the opportunity to
truly know you because if you're just
endlessly so easy about everything
to food to the tv and there's some
things i genuinely don't care about like
i'm less into tv
i'll i'll be like i'll like read a book
while my boyfriend's writing
watching tv or whatever but if you're
easy
in in the ways that
uh that you actually have feelings and
preferences about then you're doing
yourself a huge disservice like
you're not letting the person know your
true self and you're also training
yourself
to just um not speak up in a sense i
don't know if that makes
absolutely i mean you can you can bury
yourself under so many personas that you
genuinely don't know who you are anymore
like you can paint so many layers of
vanilla
over the top that you kind of you can't
crack through it to to get to the other
side
and speaking from personal experience
the girls who've been the most agreeable
the ones that i've been dating that have
been the most agreeable are the ones
i've got bored of the quickest
because it's it's kind of not it's like
dating nothing
it's like i'm not actually dating a
thing here i'm just dating this
like time delay mirror like a [ __ ] zoom
connection of what i want
like what should we watch tonight oh
well you can choose where should we go
for dinner tonight oh well you can
choose
and even if you choose something you
okay with that yeah i'm okay with that
it's like just [ __ ] push back
like just just give me something here
because
one of the things that we want from
people
i think if you come from a growth-minded
and everyone that's listening is in this
their
go-getters they're people that want to
you know enjoy life and experience
things and improve themselves
if you have that growth mindset one of
the worst things that you can do
is to not allow the other person
to grow by learning from pushing back
against them like because
they're just they're never going to feel
like you have any more layers they're
like okay
so you're telling me that basically
everything i found out about you
within the first couple of weeks of
knowing you that's all that there is to
know
because every time that i say a thing
you just fold over
like a like a limp napkin and
and then it's just me this
relationship's basically me
with some dense air and you're yeah it's
like you're driving it and the the
woman's like in a side car
it's like right there there's like i
mean i think of a good relationship is
really a car with two steering wheels
you know and like yeah you could take
your hands off the wheel because the
other person will steer
um but like yeah you don't want to be in
the side car with just
you've given up your wheel and you know
what's an and it's so easy for me to
just like go with the flow and be like
you pick cause there's
oftentimes i don't care where we eat
oftentimes i don't care what we watch
um but it's if you're a person who's
struggling with that and you're so
used to whatever you want a good place
to start is with what you
don't want like if if uh it's good to
practice this like my boyfriend would be
like what do you want to eat and i'll
genuinely think well what do i
definitely not want like i definitely
don't want pizza i definitely don't want
anything like
bready or carby and i definitely don't
want sushi because we had that last
night and then that can be an easier
way to because if you're not someone
who's used to constantly because i
always would equate it with being a
demanding chick
and and i would always be like well you
don't want to be a demanding chick
guys don't like a nag and then that got
so deep into my psyche that i just
wouldn't ask for anything because i
didn't want to be
like a demanding nag but to hear you say
like
yeah you're so a woman can be so not a
challenge that you lose interest you're
like oh no
like i don't you don't want that either
that [ __ ] sucks
yeah it's difficult it's it really is
like you don't want
as with everything the messy middle
like somewhere some nice little balance
of it all like you want enough pushback
but
then i've also dated girls who've been
so disagreeable
that every these tend to be the more
sort of intellectual ones
but like every conversation has to be
justified it ends up with a debate
like about i watched this thing and it
was really interesting about that and
then
there's a 30-minute discussion about and
i'm like look i just [ __ ] watched a
thing
i don't i don't want to have a
discussion about whether or not that guy
killed him or that guy killed him it's
like it's just
it's just a thing i watch like can we
move on and um
yeah especially as guys when dating
girls who are disagreeable
i think sometimes you can
get almost locked into a a challenge
game you enjoy the challenge
of constantly trying to slowly wear down
the
disagreeableness whereas with agreeable
girls what you're trying to do is bring
that disagreeableness
out of them so it's kind of the the
balance between the two
speaking of of dating what were the most
regular errors that you made
when dating guys
the errors that i made okay i did take
some notes here because
uh i have so much to say on this topic
the i
i um the mistakes i made personally i
was
first of all and and you guys might not
see how this is related but it ties in i
spent
way too much money like in my 20s even
through my 30s just and i think the
pandemic has like really made me
put these things into perspective like i
spent way too much money
i was a slave to consumer consumerism
instead of like
focusing on discovering my true self
like like of course it's okay to buy
stuff you know like i was so happy to
buy
all my equipment for my podcasting stuff
i'm so happy to buy
like you know even even a mug you know
you know the other day i like i did tim
pool show i bought a mug at a diner
that i was at on the way to go do that
it's like stuff like that is meaningful
to me but like i used to do so much
mindless brainless shopping
and i i think i was doing it to like
fill a void or whatever
um and i noticed the more you pull away
from just being a mindless consumer it's
almost like you do it as a stress
relief too it's like i a lot of the tv i
used to watch
like when i was much younger i would
watch kardashians and like the e-network
like celebrity stuff with my sister
because that was like our bonding
[ __ ] talking time with my mom too but
like as i grew into like myself
more i would just shop like almost to
relieve stress or to like distract
myself from like
what i'm what's really bothering me so
if you can pull away from that like
check
out of that for a while and then really
focus like deeply on like what is it
what is it that i need to pursue what
like first of all what brings me joy
what makes me feel the most alive
and like how can i pursue that
and and for a lot of people it's like
how can i pursue that despite all my
responsibilities or my day job or taking
care of my sick parents
because i think when you hang on to that
thing that's also the thing that makes
you
interesting and edgy or whatever in a
relationship
it's like yeah sure anybody can be hot
or like nice
but it's your interests that i think
make you like edgy or interesting
or like uh make a guy be like oh like
what's
what this is interesting like what's
what's under here
and it's so easy like we make fun of it
like it's so easy to just like
be basic and sort of um absorb or
consume
like the sort of basic easy culture like
any meme account
like batches or any any like no tic tac
or like memes like the classic
easy stuff that's easy to consume like
if that's if that's your whole world as
a woman like
man that's just gonna make you so like
kind of
intellectually soft and and uh you're
not doing justice to yourself
because it's because it's like if you
get to be in your 30s and you're like oh
you can't name off
four things that you [ __ ] love that's
like you haven't spelt that spent that
much time
digging you know so i would just watch
it if you find yourself
watching a lot of dumb tv or just a lot
of tv in general
and uh i think it's about really finding
those
that's your the job of your 20s i think
is like really finding your interests
because
that's gonna hold you whether or not
there's a guy in the picture
and any guy who's like truly into you
for the long run that's how you can find
out if they're
if they're worthy it's like if they if
they get your dreams and your goals and
they help you
and they support you and pursuing them
man that's that's somebody that you
gotta
look into a little bit more deeply and
sort of like see that through
and i think the mistakes i made is i
overvalued
like hot sex and lots of sex and i i
remember like there was a month where i
was just like
google calendar apps i think i it was a
month or i banged like
20 people or something but then it was
like it was like an addiction and a high
and then they would
they would leave and i'd be like who's
next you know instead of thinking like
who was gonna who was gonna be like my
personal
cheerleader or whatever who's gonna be
like my ride or die my best friend or
whatever
i overvalued hot sex and i overvalued
does the guy like me and i completely
undervalued
like communication speaking up right
because i had this
brainwashing of like oh being easy and
being agreeable means you're not being a
nag and no
man likes a nag so it was kind of i had
to deprogram that
so i had to i undervalued communication
and i undervalued me liking the guy it
was always like
am i good enough am i hot enough am i
competing
amongst these other women instead of
flipping it to like is this guy good
enough does he even have a job
you know he was late um that's so
interesting because
in relationships the sexual protagonists
are almost always the men
right the i learned this the other day
there's something called the genie
coefficient
which is a way that works out inequality
within a system
so it can work out the levels of wealth
inequality between countries
the level of the genie coefficient for
tinder
is greater than 95 percent of all
countries
oh wait genie do you mean rubbing a lamp
gene no
g it's it's the g g i n i it's like
just if it's it's just like some sort of
um
a particular formula that allows you to
work out how much inequality is in a
system
the way that it works on tinder the
bottom eighty percent of guys
are competing for the bottom 20 of girls
and the top
80 of girls are competing for the top 20
of guys so i both of those situations
you have
um a funnel that people are trying to
get past
and actually what you've said there is
totally correct if you as a girl
are aiming for that top 20 of guys
you're basically competing with
three other girls for every one guy that
you're trying
and they all have eating disorders
because so you'll never win yeah
yeah so another thing that was super
interesting
what you said it feels like girls fall
back to consumerism
a little bit they fall back to this kind
of very vanilla
um easy to consume the kardashians the
gossip the reality tv that sort of stuff
um and maybe their comfort their
girl friends what i think guys what i
think guys fall back to
on the other side of the fence is more
um
this kind of like resentfulness like
resentfulness to the world this
isolation
this um general sort of sense of anxiety
and malaise around the world out to get
them
girls sort of fall into comfortable
socializing guys fall into resentful
isolation
yeah and you see this so much like what
you've described is the default setting
of when men and women are single right
when women are single uh
there's this whole culture of like girls
and brunch and
especially if somebody in your group
just had a breakup oh it's all hands on
deck
[ __ ] men for like a good month you know
there's you gotta get bombed you know we
gotta help you find a rebound dick
like we're going shopping we're getting
you some bangs honey you know all the
worst decisions
bangs one of those is that a rebound
decision yeah a lot of times there's a
there's a
haircut there's a you know you gotta
shake things up because you're like oh
i've just suffered a blow of rejection i
gotta cut
clearly this was not working so i need
to add bangs to the equation now i'm a
new woman
now you're like i gotta try again i have
a new haircut it's blue now
um and really it's like you need to sit
down with your
maybe your patterns or hey maybe this
[ __ ] guy did you a favor
like i tripped over so many guys who
dumped me like
so many of my relationships i was the i
was the dumped i was not the dumper
right because i was like okay whatever
and despite glaring red flags i'd be
like okay and then the guy would finally
dump me thank god you know because now i
look back and i'm like oh
i would have wasted even more time if
they hadn't dumped me um
but yes the the default female culture
is like
girls you bond because maybe maybe we're
a little bit socially
um magnetic gravitating to each other
especially when we're younger it's like
this whole girl culture
going out in groups that's why you get
oh why do women go out and go to the
bathroom in groups like i was never
that chick but i totally get it because
it's just whereas with like men i think
maybe there's
and maybe there is the societal pressure
like yeah you have boys night
the man cave but like i think men are
culturally a little bit more on their
own than women whereas like women you
kind of it's okay to have a group
and so when the two sides are single
like what do you have with men like
[ __ ] women she screwed me over
she divorced me and took all my [ __ ]
cheated i mean either side can cheat of
course but like
men and women handle it differently and
and when men break off from
women like women have their friends they
have their mom
usually to [ __ ] too uh men this is why
men kind of are like i have nowhere to
put these feelings i have nobody to talk
to
i forget who said it but in a breakup
men become sort of emotionally homeless
and they just are kind of stuck and then
maybe there's the added societal
pressure of like
men can't be hurt or show feelings or
talk it out or see a therapist right so
they're kind of dealing with those
feelings on their own and then that's
when resentment and anger can
can grow with women it's kind of like we
get it we sometimes will handle breakups
better because we can purge it out with
our friends we can like
drink and dance and then when you're in
that fun single place then you're like
oh yeah
i did really like to do viable i really
like to snowboard i really like to do
art it's
it's when we're single is that we
remember who we are and we when we can
put more time into our interests because
we don't feel like we've got to
cut a chunk of ourself away for a guy
and that's like the challenge of of uh
of women is to
you can still be a good partner and not
lose yourself
you can because when you retain what you
like and you make time for it it
actually
it's healthier for both of you and it
makes you more interesting
you know to be pursued in like during
that early sort of courting time
it's um certainly from my side as well
i think the most attractive trait that i
see
in a girl is if i find them
um like ambitious
if i admire them like if you admire the
person that you're with
that's one hell especially if you're a
growth-minded person because
everyone that likes to grow looks up to
the people that they think have achieved
growth or are achieving growth and they
think wow
i wonder what i can learn from this
person if that's the way that you view
if you admire the person that you're
with it's such a
compulsive powerful draw toward them
and um i mean what's the opposite of of
admiration
like not resentment i suppose pity
tolerance
right yeah like do you really want to
tolerate or pity someone
like that's that's the precise opposite
and um yeah i would say that for girls
the thing that girls don't like about
guys based on what i've
based on what i've read in personal
experience the the biggest turn off for
girls from a guy is being needy
um and the biggest turn off or one of
the biggest turn-offs
uh for guys from a girl being at too far
at either end of that agreeableness or
disagreeableness
scale like if you're yes to everything
or no to everything
it's there's a ticking time bomb here
wow okay so if you're
like yeah if you're like a wallflower or
you're like a total [ __ ]
and it's like all right come on like you
can't eat wings and watch a game with us
you got to have your [ __ ] vegan
[ __ ] you know
like you've all been with that girl
wow how can girls tell if a guy is good
for them
oh um i think for me it was like number
one
do they support your dreams like they
would there do they treat your dreams
and your goals like they would
their own and uh that's how i kind of
knew that my current boyfriend was like
something really special because i never
had that
with anybody else i felt like i had to
be the cheerleader for the dude
but again i was like younger and
uh i didn't advocate for myself as much
but i think what my current boyfriend
did for me he
knew that sort of people pleasing part
of me the part that doesn't like to like
you know let my interest be known and he
would catch that he would be observant
and be like what do you want no really
what do you want like i picked the last
two times or like tell me
like tell me where you want to eat like
like whatever is not an answer like he
would really
kind of push me on that and draw it out
which i really needed and maybe a lot of
women need that too
is like if you catch maybe a slightly
undesirable
thing in your girl it's like don't just
like roll your eyes back
just maybe she needs help like drawing
that out
and uh because that's what the best
relationship each of you should learn
from the other and help each other grow
and
fix your your negative patterns and
stuff um
and i think yeah so it was him
supporting my dreams and goals
and it's a big part of getting into a
relationship is realizing like
your source of novelty and excitement as
you know it
will change and that's what's that's
where also the culture kind of conflicts
people are so shocked like oh why is the
divorce rate so high it's like because
our culture
kind of conflicts with the conflicts
with the values
that are needed to sustain a
relationship it's like you shouldn't be
reading advice columns written by
20 year old women who haven't you know
what i mean like
i feel like all advice columns should be
written by like 60 year olds you know or
like seven-year-olds who've like been
been in it with somebody like ben in the
[ __ ] um like don't don't listen to
dating advice from like people in their
20s like they just haven't lived enough
life and and i find a lot of these
advice pieces what they're in whether
it's news or magazine or
it's what's behind that is either
pushing some kind of political agenda or
they're pushing
products so that's why it's good to kind
of disconnect
like really evaluate where you're kind
of looking for advice like podcasts of
course are great or like
asking you know if you have an aunt and
uncle that have been together forever or
your parents if they still really like
each other
um asking them for relationship advice
is
is better i think than consulting the
sort of like the mainstream
garbage that's out there um and uh and
this
this concept women will hear this a lot
like you deserve it all don't settle
girl like you like you you basically
telling women that like
uh your self-worth is equated with not
settling which is equated with like if
you find one thing wrong and a guy like
toss him out this whole like you deserve
everything or the per
it's giving you the message that you
deserve to the perfect guy which doesn't
exist
and i fear that in the meantime you
could a woman could be tossing out or a
man could be tossing out
plenty of like really good people
you know um but it's hard to like
and and ultimately having a relationship
with someone is going to involve
right your your novelty and excitement
as you know it is gone right so it's not
the going out it's not the chase it's
not the pickup like for me i love that
[ __ ] i
loved like being picked up on like a uh
whatever weekend or whatever [ __ ] i'd
go out tuesday with my ass hanging out
and be like let's
let's do it so and that was so but you
know when you're in a relationship
you're like
okay that's you gotta find your novelty
and your excitement you have to
kind of build it from the ground up with
this person
so for me my boyfriend like we [ __ ]
love snowboarding and it kind of
generates that adrenaline and it's the
sense of achievement and it's a
challenge and we're like falling and
busting our ass and we're like laughing
about that
so and it's you can't bring your single
life
into you into a relationship so i think
the messages that
that young men and women are hearing are
not really are confusing
um not not that saying like oh there are
some elements of like
conservatism that i think help in terms
of like yeah if you want to
settle down with somebody like reassess
your values and and
i don't know i think the idea that oh
like you deserve it all like don't
settle is so damaging because
you you can waste so much time waiting
for like that perfect
person but there's no way to make the
idea of sacrifice
and working out problems like sexy do
you know what i mean like you can't
really meme that the way that you can
meme like
you deserve it all girlfriend it's just
yeah you there's the simplest answer
often like is is correct in principle
but really bad to try and push forward
like very rightly so you should demand
everything that you can
from your life you as far as we know you
only get one existence
like this is the last time that you get
to have this time
so yeah go after the things that you
want but don't be a [ __ ] about it oh
don't be a dick about it
like you don't have to hold people to
account so ruthlessly
that it sucks one of the things i'm
interested in why
what it was that you were getting
from being picked up and from that
attention
what what was it feeding in you that
you in that was a whole lot that made
you feel so good why did it feel so good
oh it hit like drugs like and i don't
know if i can fully explain why it just
felt like um
yeah like being super validating um
being desired like i just loved the
chase i like loved being chased
i loved like even sometimes now like
look at my random like dm requests and
you know just fans like i'll have a
crush on you and sometimes that'll hit
like a little spot in me that's like
you know what i mean um maybe it's deep
down there's a fear of like
being taken for granted or um
abandoned i don't really know i just
know that it's it's always
and i'm somebody who like when i'm at my
low vibrational
like left in my own devices if i were
single and like not in a good place
oh boy could i be a huge [ __ ] in like no
time flat and that would be the only
thing i would do
you know i wouldn't because i look back
at the times where i was like that oh i
didn't pursue
[ __ ] except for dick like i was like
dick
appointments you know what i mean i was
like yeah that's nice but i am late for
my next dick appointment and then it
would be
if it's bad it's a joke it's a story but
if it's great man it's
great you tell your girlfriends about it
maybe that ends up in your stand-up set
too and just um
it was this feeling of like i maybe i'm
a dude deep down like it was this
feeling of like um
like the chase or just like really i
would get in my head i would like
about adding up my numbers and um
just like um i don't know i don't know
what was behind it i
i think uh people would listen to this
and say oh daddy issues classic you know
maybe um i never had like a great dads i
don't know what to compare it to like
oh he was great like yeah he he paid for
[ __ ] he would fix my car but like he
never really asked me like
what i thought or felt or like
talked to me about the [ __ ] that it was
important to me so i wonder what it's
going to be like
i can't wait to be a dad and i
i wonder what it's going to be like if i
have girls
like trying to communicate to girls
because like even the wife that you've
got you don't have to communicate in the
way that you do from a guy
to a to a girl it is it must be
the chasm that you have to leap
linguistically conceptually
emotionally spiritually like it's a
it's a big old a big old hole thinking
about
the big hole thinking about
the um i've been called worse the way
that
girls often go in and out of
relationships like everyone's got that
girl friend i think it's i have it
personally in my experience it's more
right with guys
to have the one that is just like
maximum
length of time being single is sort of
three and a half weeks
and it's like one ovulation you get one
ovulation single
and then and then you're back in the
relationship again throw out your scent
again yeah you gotta get back out there
that's why everybody's working on cop
cars in miami right now
wow um oh god now i wonder if that was
me no i went
um i'm in a couple yeah it was a couple
months between my last
couple boyfriends oh it's um everyone
i remember my friends gave me [ __ ] like
oh you rushed into another relationship
wouldn't necessarily base it on that
because if you're not you can also take
time for yourself
in a relationship you may not need to be
uh i need to take six months or a year
off of dick to find myself like i've
heard
women do that but you should be able to
also find yourself or
reclaim yourself in a relationship too
like those are good skills
it's that whole like up have i lost
myself
am i cranky am i angry irritable oh
maybe that means i'm not doing what i
want to do
or like um i feel tense oh i'm not i'm
not like saying my true feelings i'm
feeling stagnant yeah that probably
means something needs to move
emotions isn't it interesting that all
of those things there
i think are probably a lot rarer to
finding guys so those are the things
that guys can rely on like if a guy
gets single at least sort of within my
friend group they'll lean into their
business they'll lean into their
entrepreneurship
they'll lean into reading more
meditating more training more
um that's where they'll go for strength
whereas that might be somewhere that
girls would go
for weakness or where they would shy
away from is where men would lean into
i think i have known like
women like yeah you when you are single
it's like oh yeah
like now i have time for myself again
which sometimes that does mean working
out more
you're back to your like single single
girl schedule and it's like you probably
would fill in that
boyfriend time with like friend time or
like yeah
trying to get dick time depending on
like how you take it
how you take the break up it's always
good to
yeah maybe men are healthier in that way
like yeah i'm going to focus on my
business or
strengthen my body my mind like yeah
that's uh and it sucks it shouldn't take
a break up
for us to kind of recalibrate and
reprioritize those things because
man those things are so important all
the time it makes you a better you it
makes
you a better more interesting partner
so it's uh i think we waste a lot of
time being like oh whose fault was it
what's wrong with me i need to talk to
them and
i need more chances or oh you got to
figure it out like
sometimes things fall apart and that
that's i don't know
if you believe in god or whatever like
things are meant to happen and
it's like one of you might want to get
back together
okay like see and see what happens there
but like
yeah sometimes the breakup can be the
best thing
and uh maybe that person breaks up with
you or you break up with them and
it allows you to like uh just
recalibrate on your whole [ __ ]
um but i think uh
god did i talk about you were asking
oh yeah this is like what women do like
we uh
a lot of us don't ask for things like
right in relationships like we've
discussed but also in our careers
and that can lead to so much stagnation
because you think like
oh um if i were good enough like they
would just hand me the thing or the or
the promotion
or the raise or whatever and i learned
like
you know i learned it eventually but it
would be nice to learn this
maybe 10 years ago it's like [ __ ] you
have to ask for it you have to demand it
especially when it comes to your career
and your goals like
be [ __ ] annoying be the follow-up
circle back queen
you know um and it and like
and you won't be annoying it's okay like
when it comes to business like
you have to just learning to not take
things personally
is also one of like the best lessons
because if someone's not giving you what
you think you want or need in a
relationship like
oh they're not spending as much on me
for my birthday as i spent on them for
their birthday
oh man just try to take [ __ ] like that
not like that's how
a woman's empathy and um almost like our
psychic abilities can come back and like
[ __ ] us up you know uh because you're so
observant you're able to see the
differences
yeah like oh i spent 500 on his birthday
and i feel like he spent like barely
anything online does that mean he
doesn't really
love me as much or is he cheap or it's
like he might just be clueless he might
just have like no clue
um what to get you and it took me a
couple years in my relationship to learn
like i gotta send him a cup even though
it feels weird
i gotta send him a couple links of
things i want like
birthday or christmas which i was so
hesitant to do because
me that felt like i'm being needy i'm
i'm being too
asky i'm being too demanding oh my god
like
once i unhooked like i thought
everything was being [ __ ] too
demanding
there's another side of that coin as
well which is like he should know if he
cared
yeah there's so much of that like i felt
that way about bosses
boyfriends family members because like i
feel like i'm super perceptive
and can figure things out well if i'm
this perceptive of them
and we've been together the same six
years why can't he perceive
things in me and then you take that
personally
um so yeah your superpower can also be
your [ __ ]
greatest weakness as well or the thing
that
uh screws you over but i think another
important like piece of advice is
you get and for me i would always be
somebody who would get
have to get advice from all my friends
like with any breakup like oh what do i
do you hash it out
just to make sure that you like you know
you weren't the person in the wrong oh
he sucks he sucks you have to get that
validation that like you're still okay
and uh it can be so easy to get advice
from so many other people but like
the more you can tune into yourself and
uh the more you can rely on yourself as
the person you get advice from oh
the better all the better because let's
say your best friend is out of the
country and you're having a crisis and
you're like well i can't [ __ ]
function unless i talk to theresa it's
like
the more you can rely on yourself even
even right now like
i've been seeing my therapist for like i
think four years
and i think i'm about to break up with
her honestly over politics like it's
it's starting to bother me like um yes
yeah and uh and i'm realizing like i
think it's okay and i remember this is
the same therapist who like
told me at one point like yeah maybe you
might need to break up with like my
current boyfriend like
of course we've had ups and downs and i
remember she like
and i was like i think a younger chrissy
would have been like gotta listen to the
therapist
she's the professional but like there
was just something in me that was like
no
just like work on this like that was
just you know
saying like pull through he's a good guy
or whatever and uh
and now it's like oh yeah because i
started seeing her because my mom was
like diagnosed with cancer and i was
feeling the stagnation in my
relationship but i realized that's just
because i wasn't
communicating enough like it wasn't any
time
it feels like tense it's like it's just
gotta emotions have to move through like
they can get stuck
just like a muscle can get sore or
whatever
you just gotta like keep talking that's
like no it's number one and it's so hard
but
oh yeah at least like recently with my
therapist like i was finding
like she's she's in new york like she's
super liberal and like i've found in the
last
couple years like i've been getting i've
been pulling away from like kind of
liberal
i'm becoming like less woke you know
like kind of anti-woke even
and uh i think i brought up that i voted
for trump and i think after that she
started a little bit
i don't know i could just perceive this
slight bit of like
judgment and i was like oh i think i
need to break up with her and then
here's what she said that made me
realize like oh [ __ ] maybe i don't need
this therapist anymore
she said like oh but like she's raising
these her rates
and then she said to me like well i know
a couple who makes less than you
and they can pay it and i was like oh
oh that's that's interesting
so it's weird sometimes just like our
parents or our therapists they can
sometimes reveal
their personhood instead of their like
heroic
uh you know person who gives you advice
or something like we're all just [ __ ]
people at the end of the day you know
do you have the more you can like look
within and be like does it
tune into your gut and like does this
feel right
am i missing something am i am i serving
myself am i feeding my am i listening to
my inner child
like what's the stuff you like to you
like to do as a kid and
you haven't done that in a really long
time like okay well it's probably time
to make time for that i love that
i love that advice i tell people that so
much whatever you did for fun between
the ages of like 8 and 14
you will adore doing when you're 32 like
it
it's just awesome although i went back
and played a sport that i hadn't played
in a decade and ruptured my achilles the
first time that i did it so
like condition yourself before you go
back into
right because i started giving [ __ ]
at 14 which
oh god one of the things that's super
interesting
is um for guys i think there is a
a really important inflection point that
we all get to at like 27
28 29 somewhere a little bit later
and it's what i've dubbed the menopause
so it's a change when you
let go of the old
quite juvenile really based transient
relationships
you start to realize okay like i need to
understand what the word
integrity means maybe i don't need to
have it just yet but at least i need to
understand what it means
i can't continue to get wasted and get a
couple of bags in on a weekend and sniff
my head off with the boys until monday
morning and then
like not really do anything like i can't
do that like i need to
i need to knuckle down and try and do
stuff and that
seems to be really formative i know
there's tons and tons of guys that are
of that age group that are
going through the menopause right now
and are trying to come out on the other
side as this
much more aligned much more awakened
better understood human what are the
key ages that you found or what are the
ones that your girlfriends
went through where you saw these real
profound changes that's so interesting
that you say that first of all because
like around the age of 28
is also um and i don't want people that
are like not into astrology to
immediately tune out but like 28 is also
the age of like your saturn return
and it's a it's a year of like a lot of
sort of like change in growing up and
things are coming together
and you're sloughing off like old
[ __ ]
so i'm sure that's part of it um it's so
different for women because we have the
added
uh thing of am i do i want to have kids
or not and and i would say just
you don't want to start thinking about
that like if you don't want to start
thinking about kids until you're 35 that
sucks because it might take you a few
years to even find
somebody like decent who would be a good
dad
so even if you're even if you're sitting
here listening at 30 and you're like i
definitely don't want kids
it's like yeah if you approach finding
a guy almost like who would be a good
dad i think you'll ultimately end up
with a better partner
and uh and it's and that's the thing is
like hooking up is so fun
oh man but now looking back i know that
like
there's only really 10 or 12 different
kinds of dudes
and and it's like you know you don't
need four five
six rounds of that you know now looking
back it's like
yeah i had a lot of type ones two sevens
i had a lot of twelves you know like
like you don't you know it's fun to be
like single and
and [ __ ] i had a great time but it's
like now going back it's like yeah i
would have been good
sleeping with half of the guys that i
slept with like i didn't need to have
that many experiences because a lot of
them were the same
you're gonna have a lot of like ah the
really hot guy that's out of your league
not talking to anybody on this podcast
of course or like you know the guy with
a really great job and he's like not too
good looking or
or like whatever the guy who's like kind
of short but he's obsessed with you or
like
uh the bro comedian or like uh the rich
finance guy who's cheating on you it's
like you don't need to have all those
experiences
six times so it's like um
not that i would and that's the thing is
like of course i have all this
looking back i can say like yeah i was
uh
the idea is just to like figure out what
you want
sooner rather than later so i would say
like
yeah when you're out of college or at a
school or whatever whatever like
that's the thing if your goals are in
line if you really are like
it's the gro the growth mentality is
truly everything
because if you want to build something
and you have dreams
it's like that has to stay primary and
then whoever comes into that is either
going to support that and if they don't
well then they need to go
because like don't lose sight of what
you want to build
and that could just be that you know
that doesn't mean you have to be ceos
like
maybe the thing you want to build is a
family which is totally cool but
um try to figure that out sooner rather
than later
because it's like the the goal is to not
waste time
right and and even if you're not so set
on your goals be like okay what do i
just
value you know whether it's hanging out
with your family on the weekends or
like for me a big lesson was like my
boyfriend has a
has a son and i started dating him the
kid was like
four years old now he's 10. and the
thing that i struggled with was like
uh basically like why why am i not
getting all the attention like i really
had to struggle with like
chunking off a lot of our boyfriend
girlfriend time is like his dad time
because he would see his kid every other
weekend
and like man like that was a good lesson
for me to have because
i was also a person who struggled with
like needing a lot of attention so
it was almost like i finally came to the
conclusion of like
kristi you kind of need to grow up in a
way like this kid didn't ask to be
born um he's he doesn't solely exist
just to keep you from having sex you
know
i started seeing him as his own like own
person
and uh hey what unique strengths of mine
can i sort of impart on him or how can i
you know i mean how can i give like the
best of myself
to this like young person and uh and now
i'm this
sort of cool step girlfriend and we like
and i feel like my sense of humor is
rubbed off on him but it was
in the beginning i was like oh he's got
the [ __ ] kid again
like this you know what i mean like i
really was struggling with it
it's hard to date somebody with a kid
but uh
always look for like what you can learn
in the situation
i don't even know if i'm answering the
question no i think that you are and
one of the interesting things that um
that comes up when you you look at the
path of people that haven't got their
goals sorted out
is they do just get blown by the wind
the sad thing is i wonder
we can all look back with the wonderful
perspective of wisdom right and x number
of years i'm 33 you said you're 37.
look back and go god all of the stuff
that
i now take for granted or that i sorry
all of the stuff that i value
is so obvious like it's so plain
it's now written into the source code of
the way that i see the world
like i obviously could have realized
this at 21
or however many guys instead of double
the number of guys
or whatever it might be less than a
hundred okay
so i could have obviously reached this
because to me now
these realizations are so obvious but
one of the problems is
it's not just about having the lessons
written out
in a bulleted list and this is why i
think that podcasts are so important
because your life isn't changed by an
instagram quote
when you're scrolling through why
because there's no context
you're going like booty picture booty
kick picture funny cat video booty
picture
inspirational quote funny cat video like
you need
the context around the message that
you're getting you need to hear it from
a thousand different angles
and a hundred different people you need
all of the different
examples and you said like you don't
need to date the same guy
with a different name and a different
face six times to learn the lesson you
could have learned from the first one
but lessons are quite hard learned
sometimes like you do need to hammer
them home
with a number of different mallets as it
sounds like you were hit with
and um then like
this is sounding so sexual you keep
bringing it up
and um yeah i just think that they're
really hard
learned these lessons are super super
difficult to to get into your head
but certainly focusing on what it is
that you want to do
and not taking things i think everybody
takes stuff too seriously
especially when you when you're 21 the
whatever the thing is that's happening
has probably at most happened maybe once
or twice before
so obviously it's going to be a big deal
if this is only your second breakup or
maybe your first breakup
it's going to be massive because you've
never had one before when you're on
breakup number 20
inevitably just the size of the waves is
going to be smaller because the scale of
the map that you're looking at is going
to be less
so yeah i think um we can berate your
thing we can berate ourselves over not
arriving at our realizations earlier
but on the flip side of that i
i wonder how much how quick we can
iterate on it in any case if you're
23 and single and love like drinking
margaritas and partying with your
girlfriends thursday friday saturday
every week like you're not in the place
to even receive the message
even if you got it yeah
yeah and it's just like i guess it's
like you don't
learn it until you learn it
it's so wild because you can't uh right
like and i remember i hated hearing when
i was in my 20s oh you go to have a kid
soon
i [ __ ] hated hearing that you know
like i i would hear it from my mom and
i'd be like i don't i'm not even with a
guy i like
you know i mean i hated um
you know i would move from apartment to
apartment i'd be renting forever and my
mom would be like
and i would just be like oh i want to
buy like a nice bed or a nice
chest of drawers or something and she'd
be like no don't when you settle down
like she would almost
shame me for renting and uh i hated that
because i was like
oh and in her eyes i'm not like good
enough to buy like a
good piece of furniture yet be like what
um
so some people are so at odds with like
what their parents are telling them to
do
um yeah so that's the [ __ ] of it is
like for women because it's like
you could be so convinced you don't want
to have kids in your 20s or even through
your 30s and you could wake up like
in your 40s and be like [ __ ] i really
want to have a kid so
that's the challenge right like that's
that's the big elephant in the room i
think of
of modern life especially for women um
a really reassuring stat is that in the
uk more women had children over the age
of 40 than under the age of 20 last year
whoa yeah wow which is pretty cool
um but there are some challenges
that girls face now you think about the
loss of tradition of marriage the
increase in transient sex the fact that
allowing women into the workplace with
more equality
actually makes them have to make a
really difficult decision because
previously if there was no career on the
table you didn't have to choose between
career and family
like obviously in a democratic society
that's a meritocracy where you can be
anything you want to be
we love the idea of giving people
choices but the paradox of choice can
hurt
because when you have a choice to make
that's on you
you're always going to think about
whether or not you made the right one
whereas if you're just pushed into one
direction people oddly are actually more
satisfied with the outcome
so i'm not i'm not saying that we need
to go back to
not allowing women in the workplace but
my point is that dispensaries
yeah despicable just stay at home
reading dr seuss books
and dispensing with the traditions of
the past means that
you now have challenges that there
aren't any
um existing narratives to give you the
solution to
like we don't know what it's like for
women to be in the workplace for more
than like
40 years or 50 years properly but this
experiment is two generations long and
we think that we understand how it works
it's really challenging so yeah um it's
really challenging and then there's like
this whole fear like
oh like you gotta get a job with health
benefits so you can have the kid but
you don't want to get hired and then
immediately take off because you're
pregnant too soon because that looks bad
are you gonna get [ __ ] for that are you
then gonna get [ __ ] for
taking uh like a leave of absence some a
maternity leave and then
someone gonna take your job before
before you come back some you know
can that happen surely that can't happen
some cat-loving [ __ ] comes in and takes
your job you know like i don't know
you never know right because you're away
and especially with new york city
there's like this
but pre-pandemic was a such like
every job feels like devil wears prada
there's just so much competition
and uh hustle and like everyone's at
your throat
it's just like and uh so it's like oh
you finally
take off to have this kid and like uh
when you come back
are you seen as like uh like problematic
or like uh you know uh
too demanding oh i gotta take off from
my kids i gotta leave
concerts meetings and then is your boss
gonna like roll your eyes and be like
ugh
you were a lot more committed when you
were [ __ ] 21 with no kid
it's really hard it's so hard and and i
would i'm gonna blame the culture for a
lot of this because
man does the culture make it so easy to
instead of like learn let's say you need
to learn a lesson a pattern a toxic
pattern about yourself
whatever it's from your parents or
whatever and instead of like learning
that lesson with that
with guy number one you're like well uh
we had that first argument goodbye
back on the app swipe swipe swipe you're
you're fresh
right with guy number two but you're
you're like and let's say that issue
doesn't come up for another three months
oh well part of you is like i don't want
to learn that lesson oh he's a dick
dump you know back on the app swipe
swipe you're with guy number three
same issue comes up six months in you
know what i mean like so now
a lesson you could have learned in a
month has now taken maybe a year because
we're in this like disposable
people are kind of disposable that uh
you know
there's unlimited options on the apps
you can always there's so many more fish
in the sea but like
is it possible that you just delayed you
learning that lesson
out a year and some people do that for
i mean many many years they'll avoid
learning lessons
so i'll tell you what's weird the
boiling down of the culture to its
simplest terms you talked about
tick-tock and meme culture earlier on
that really does reduce down all the
context that we were saying
drives these points home and allows you
to understand the lessons
it if you turn something into a lovely
pithy little aphorism like if anything
is the length of a tweet
you probably need to know more than just
that to fully understand it like that's
that's a pretty good rule to use
but because we're living on social media
and it's
this real transactional transient just
communication about
what does it rhyme has it got clap
emojis in between each word is there a
full stop at the end
like all of these things somehow that's
it that's the tweet
they make the truthfulness of the of the
statement somehow seem better and you're
like
it doesn't change the actual the
intellectual
uh realism of whatever somebody's
talking about
isn't affected by their emoji use but
what we do you just sound cuntier like
you've just made
the voice of the tweet sound like a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] person is saying this like
who put some
emoji collapse in between each thing and
that's the thing is like we're all like
a lot of us
are copycats you see other people doing
oh this person's cool they have a lot of
followers i'll start doing that
and yeah it's so true what you said
about needing context so much of twitter
is like
inside jokes or or people talking to
their people
right like just today i made like inside
jokes
i made it like a stand-up comedy inside
joke i said like um
i'm like you know when you're at a
comedy club and there's like this drunk
girl and she's an attention [ __ ] and
she's heckling and she's ruined
everybody's time
and everyone's like she's so annoying
and then finally that girl leaves and
everybody claps
that's what chrissy teagan leaving
twitter feels like which is
really like yes that requires context
but if you know you know
and it's funny so but twitter wasn't
designed for context
no it wasn't and the other thing as well
is that
when you boil that down people don't
want to learn difficult lessons because
the obvious stuff should be so obvious
and that's why you said like oh you're
too good for him or
you know like clapping back like what do
you what do you mean like you've you've
created an entire like intellectual
subsection
based around a [ __ ] emoji like that's
yeah clapping back that just means you
don't want to like learn a hard lesson
about yourself
probably clapping back no maybe
maybe if you just like uh maxed out too
many credit cards maybe he needs to look
at your finances instead of clapping
back i don't know like
one thing it's a bad aid one thing that
i thought that might be interesting is
do you think there's any traits that
guys
should take from girls are there any
things that girls do that
guys would benefit from like adding into
their emotional or social repertoire
yeah i think guys could be a little bit
better at like reaching out to their
friends i think
sometimes guys they get too uh like
they feel like they have to deal with
all their [ __ ] on their own like in
their own heads
and uh just just from like
guys that i'm close to like yeah it's
almost like right you don't want to
become emotionally homeless like almost
like have your
keep in touch with your not saying like
you could be dumped at any time
or divorced at any time like but like
keep up with your guy friends
um like really try to put extra effort
in that because it's so easy to just
like
let the days and weeks and months and
i'm sure we could all think of
just now in the last year like man
there's a handful of people i haven't
talked to in a really long time but i
think
there's something about guys that just
maybe they're all so focused on work
and then maybe their wife and their kid
is a handful and then it seems like the
first thing to go when a guy settles
down
are his friends which is so sad because
i think women are better
at keeping in touch like stereotypically
so i would say yeah
like for guys like don't don't lose your
your friends because i think
some of them think oh well they have
kids they're they're not going to be
down for like the group snowboarding
trip anymore you have to eliminate like
a whole swath of friends that have kids
and
they that sucks they probably feel like
like don't i guess don't count anybody
out
automatically i think a reverse of that
is
if you are the guy that's got a lot of
stuff going on remember that when your
friends offer you to do stuff
if you say no enough times they're going
to stop offering you to do stuff
like because i know what it's like if
you're running a business or trying to
do things or even just focusing
obsessively neurotically focusing on
yourself
doing self-work in a way which you know
is making you a better person
but when someone decides to reach out to
say hey man like do you want to go for
food this week or something leave them
red
like no no like i mean like oh like
can't do it
or uh too busy this week or whatever it
might be it's like
you don't have no one has that many
friends
nobody has a sufficient friends to be a
dick to the friends that you have
so yeah i think um on both sides of it
remember to continue to sort of keep in
touch with the people that you should
but also remember to be responsive when
that happens
it's so easy for guys especially the
ones that are in relationships
the combination of the elitist like i'm
in a relationship and you're not like
[ __ ] off i get i get sex on tap along
with the
the misses might give me stick i might
get in trouble by i don't almost don't
want to ask
like ah i hear so much of that from like
my boyfriend's friends like oh i gotta
ask the boss it's like
ugh who wants to be part of something
like that i don't know maybe that's just
me
not being like a typical like
chick it's a very common among
like past relationships but that's born
out of the girl being
insecure around you not liking her
sufficient
sufficiently um the
subtext of i'm going out with my friends
is you are choosing your friends over me
which is you don't like me sufficiently
so really really where it comes from is
you just needing to say
look i want to spend time with you i
enjoy spending it's
it's a reassurance it's a cry out for
attention and reassurance
but god it gets so old so quick and you
can only take a few of those before it
before it sort of starts to and it'll
it'll totally degrade the relationship
because if if everything that a guy
has to do outside of the relationship he
knows he's going to come with this
like
yeah well this mcdonald's happy meal of
like extra toys and there's a bag of
grapes and all of this other stuff that
i need to
i need to eat before i can actually get
to the [ __ ] meal
you don't have those in america do you
just you just have a little slices
yeah but they're deep fried aren't they
they're deep fried and they're inside of
a doughnut you need to eat the donut to
get to the
to get to them yeah there's apple slices
inside of a doughnut
they'll give you like a bag of like wet
apple slices that are like obviously
there's some kind of preservative
in there keeping them like from going
you know brown
um but that's so interesting and it's
like it's good to think of yourself as
like even if you're the best girlfriend
or wife ever it's like
you're still just one color and uh
you need there's certain colors that
he's not going to get from you
like you get a color like you're trying
everyone's trying to be a rainbow right
whatever
but it's like a woman's like you you
might be a great blue you're a great
shade of blue but you're still blue and
like maybe working out
is yellow and his you know his business
or his feeling of building something
okay that's orange
and maybe like kids are red or like
whatever
like playing guitar is the purple and
it's like you can't don't even try to be
all the colors like don't try to be that
don't be the cheesecake factory that
thinks it's so good at making
god i [ __ ] love the cheesecake
factory oh really maybe
no no no so i get it's a perfect it's a
perfect analogy for what you're talking
about
but god the cheesecake factory is
phenomenal like that place the fact that
i mean like the pizza place that also
tries to do chinese food
okay yeah i wish i don't know if they
have them in the uk they
every time that i go to america and it's
so bad because all of my american
friends
look down on me i love denny's denny's
to me i'm like
they do college unbelievable breakfast
they're open at like
5 30 a.m for no reason at all
they still haven't closed and yet also
haven't opened yet
and um yeah ihop diners yeah that means
you're like uh
not high maintenance yeah i get down
with olive garden like oh
why not applebee's yeah i love it
look chrissy uh i really really
appreciate you coming on hopefully we've
saved some people some girls and maybe
some guys from uh
making some awful mistakes where should
people go they want to check out more of
your stuff
i hope so yeah yeah i would say like the
number one thing is like
do they care about your goals uh yeah
check me out
on all things social media at chrissy
mayer um
check out the chrissy mayer podcast
which is on itunes youtube spotify
soundcloud chris was on an episode
really really wonderful um i'll do
interviews with
like literally everybody political
personalities libertarians porn stars
comedians like there's something for
everybody
and then i have a show called the wet
spot on compound media which is a
subscriber based
network uh mondays at 7 30 pm
eastern and that's like a sex dating
relationship like fluffy fun
advice show but yeah like my podcast
stuff is all
free so check that out and yeah follow
me on all the things and i
am doing stand up i have a huge stand up
tour if you're listening if you're in
the u.s at all just go to my website
chrissymayer.com
for tickets like i'll be going to you
know delaware florida
oklahoma austin nashville alabama
cleveland appleton so check it out sick
is your tim pool episode up yet as well
oh yes it is yeah i was uh i was just on
temple on monday so that's
up if you want to check that out yeah we
talk about like comedy cancel culture
stuff which is always fun
awesome thank you for coming on thanks
chris
[Music]
you